thank you it's such a treat to be here
you all are literally my favorite people
in the world to work with if you look
around the room you'll actually see the
people who are inventing the future of
productivity and what I wanted to do to
start us off today is to talk a little
bit about how we view productivity at
Microsoft with a goal of trying to
engage you in some of the key challenges
that we have because as a company we
understand that research is fundamental
to building the products that we create
and you can see the importance of
research show up in our company in
unexpected ways and this is one of my
favorite so you all are probably
familiar with mark Weiser he was
considered the founder of ubiquitous
computing and was a chief scientist at
Xerox PARC back in the early 80s but
what you may not know is that our CEO
Satya Nadella is also very familiar with
mark Weiser's work and such a really
likes this quote from a scientific
American article that Mark wrote back in
1991 titled
the computer for the 21st century and in
that article he said the most profound
technologies are those that disappear
the most profound technologies are those
that disappear they weave themselves
into the fabric of everyday life until
they are indistinguishable from them and
if you want proof that your research
and what you're doing is important you
need only look at the fact that
Microsoft now thirty years later is
working to make that vision that Mark
had a reality we're we're working to
make computers disappear now obviously
Microsoft loves computers you know we
know that this is working now there is
just slow so obviously Microsoft loves
computers we owe our existence to
computers you may be familiar with this
quote this is from Bill Gates which was
our initial mission statement that
Microsoft was built to put a computer on
every desk and in every home but you
know technology has become so ubiquitous
that a mission statement like this just
doesn't make sense anymore sure you've
got a computer on your desk and at home
you've got a computer in your pocket and
in your bag and in your car and in your
lights which technology has embedded so
deeply in the world around us that the
thing that matters is what it enables us
to do and this is reflected in
Microsoft's current mission statement
which is to empower every person and
every organization on the planet to
achieve more and you'll notice there's
nothing in there about the computer and
where you're supposed to put it you know
and you guys know this right my
computing has just become so embedded in
everything that it's impacting our lives
our work our society our legal systems
our economic systems and this is all the
result of a perfect
shift that started back in the early 90s
when Mark Weiser wrote that Scientific
American article and the thing that's
really helped to drive that shift is the
web so as we look to the future of
productivity and where we're going as a
research field and as an organization
and as a society it's useful to look
back to understand that the changes that
the web has brought about so far now I
want you to think about the first time
that you saw the web and those of you
who are under 30 don't remember but I do
I remember being in this dungeon of a
computer lab at my undergrad Institute
and this guy called me over he's like
Jamie come check this out and he showed
me my very first web page through the
links browser now at the time the web
was entirely text-based you may remember
having a tab around to get between links
and click return to follow any of them
honestly not it was really dumb
fortunately I wasn't too dumb to
recognize that that guy was someone
special and we're now married with four
kids but I wasn't completely wrong about
the way by either it just wasn't that
useful at that point but it did open the
door to two key shifts the first is it
created lightweight ways for people to
communicate so much so that it Microsoft
we now consider collaboration a
fundamental part of every product we
build a product that doesn't include
collaboration is broken but we're only
just starting to understand how online
collaboration is going to change the way
that we work and
we live as it becomes increasingly easy
to pull together the right people at the
right time in the right context and the
emergence of platform mediated work it's
gonna change the organizations that
Microsoft has created to serve and the
products that we build and there's a
couple of sessions that the faculty
summit looking at this shift now the
second shift that the way brought about
oh and I didn't show in advance my
slides sorry it was something pretty
about connecting people but the second
key shift is that the web made it
possible for us to observe people's
interactions with software at scale so
you know how I thought the web was dumb
the thing that changed my mind was web
search web content becomes useful once
you can find it okay I was so excited
about web search that I went to work at
an early search engine called Infoseek
and then I went on to get my doctorate
in information retrieval but while I was
right that web search was gonna be
transformative
I was actually wrong about why you know
I thought we were building this Oracle
to the all the world's knowledge or you
could ask any question and get an answer
we've made amazing progress on this
front but what I missed was that it was
how'd this happen what happened that
matters the way that web search engines
got to be as good as they are today is
behavioral data web search engines see
the queries that people issue and the
results that they click and they use
this information to get better
and while this was new with web search
engines it's now the way every product
you use is built every product engages
people and that engagement
produces behavioral data and that
behavioral data is then fed back into
the system to create better products
which in turn drives more engagement and
these feedback loops are driven by you
they're driven by research they're
driven via experimentation where we use
behavioral data to compare two different
versions of a system and they're driven
via artificial intelligence where we
feed that data back into the system so
that the system itself can directly
learn and the research that we all are
doing on the future of productivity it's
not a thing about the actual future it's
directly relevant right now to the
products we are building now but you
know we need to be thoughtful about this
because somewhere along the way we seem
to have mistaken engagement for the end
goal so much so that our computing
devices now drive our attention I mean
did you know that people notice their
phone is missing before they notice
their wallet is missing what's more
people notice their phone is missing
before they notice their kids are
missing and I know that sounds
ridiculous but I'm pretty sure it would
be true for me and my four boys are very
noisy now your father wasn't built to
capture your attention
was actually built to connect you with
other people and then later to connect
you with information but somewhere along
the line as the applications on your
phone started using your data to get
better it became something you couldn't
put down and we need to flip this around
if computing is gonna become part of the
fabric of everything the way mark Y's
are predicted it can't distract us it
has to help us focus on the things that
matter and to do this we need to put
people at the center of our feedback
loops because engagement is not the end
goal their success is and this is where
our research comes in and it gets really
interesting
because there's all sorts of things we
need to do to figure out how to do this
you know we need to get people to tell
us what success means for them you know
that means capturing their intent it
means asking them it means understanding
natural language it means understanding
the context that they're in it means
figuring out what matters to them
helping them prioritize what's important
we also need to figure out richer kinds
of data to collect and to build and grow
our tools on more than just behavioral
data for example we have a product
called workplace intelligence that helps
organizations understand their
organizational data and use that to
create a more engaged workforce and
workplace intelligence is essentially
allowing us to tie our systems of
engagement to our customer systems of
record we're also starting to capture
information about how the content that
people create is consumed so that it's
not just big companies that are using
feedback loops and understanding how
data how their information is used as a
way to improve but every person we're
empowering people to use that statement
formation to create better content
and you know we also need to sometimes
engage people directly in the system
because right now most of the learning
we do is based on this implicit feedback
that people provide but people know so
much more than just labels and so we
need to use things like machine teaching
to engage people and telling us about
the structure the problems are thinking
about and about the reasons why they
think something is important or not by
placing people at the center of our
feedback loops we make it possible to
create productivity tools that don't
just get more engaging the more they're
used but they actually get better but I
actually think the most interesting
thing is I can finish finish the impact
and think about how these feedback loops
not only impact our products but how
they can impact the people that use the
products because there's an opportunity
to use these same feedback loops to not
just help people and not just help the
products get better but actually help
people get better the more they use them
because the fact is the fact that
software impacts our attention it
doesn't have to be a bad thing it can
impact our attention in a way that helps
us accomplish the things that matter and
you can see this starting to show up in
some of the products were building as
well so for example we have a tool
called my analytics that helps reflect
on your own productivity data and think
about how you can be doing things better
you know it might give you a nudge if
you're gonna send in After Hours email
to somebody to be like people don't you
know don't bug people now let them have
the rest we also have something called
the present the presenter coach which
help uses speech understanding and
natural language to understand and help
you improve your presentation skills to
help you with pacing to help you not say
um and AH help you use more inclusive
language and so to make these things
that I've just talked about
more concrete I'd like to share a video
of some of the ways that Microsoft is
working to help our products and the
people who use them get better over time
how are the majestic information worker
in his natural environment here we
witness an important ritual the creation
of the sales presentation see how he
boldly distilled mountains of
information into a clear coherent
message moved the strong challenge and
novelty of his work the unshakable focus
the clear-eyed dedication
triumphant he brings the fruits of his
labor to his clients truly a remarkable
display through the power of AI
Microsoft 365 learns from you as you use
it
bringing focused clarity and impact to
the work you do every day my analytics
shows you where you're spending your
time and windows focus assist keeps you
on task by filtering out and essential
notifications ideas flow for research to
intelligent analysis that learns from
you defines insights in your data
without the grunt work communicate more
effectively with built-in intelligence
that helps refine your ideas as you work
task management and collaboration happen
right in the app without breaking your
workflow and integration with teams
makes communications seamless it's
easier than ever to find and reuse
existing content with a Microsoft search
while ideas and word provides useful
guidance to enhance your writing
[Music]
when it's time to build the presentation
perfectly provides design ideas such as
supporting visuals and bricks complex
figures into something more relatable
with every suggestion it learns a little
more about what works for you
there are even intelligent features to
help you improve your presentation
skills and strategies so nothing gets
between you and your audience tools that
learn from you how do you grow and
empower you to succeed wherever you are
that's the promise of my preceptory
system
[Music]
so there was a lot going on in that
video and I'm just gonna take you
quickly through a couple of the clusters
of things that I think are particularly
important to pay attention to so the
first thing I want to draw your
attention to is that there's a lot of
places where you see technology
augmenting people's existing
interactions with other people and with
the people places and things in their
world that matter this is sort of what
we were talking about at the start with
computers disappearing you know with the
focus moving to what people are doing
instead of what they instead of like on
the computer and the cool thing about
this is you actually can start seeing
ways that we're making the world better
it's not just about getting keeping
technology from getting in the way of
your face-to-face interactions are
getting in the way of how you interact
with the world but actually augmenting
it you see that with teams where we blur
the background or make it easier to see
the content that you want to see um
hololens is another great example of
where we're really pushing the
boundaries there we've got it instances
of hololens deployed on the factory
floor where you can get remote
assistants to help you figure out how to
do things so if you're not an expert at
fixing this particular device somebody
else can come in and help guide you
through that process in the in the
actual experience of doing it so that's
thinking about how we can use technology
to help what people are doing now and
you and you see a lot of that but what's
harder to capture in a video is how
these tools are getting better with use
where these feedback loops are actually
improving things but you can see in the
video where we're capturing the data
that's necessary to improve those
systems and one of the examples I really
like here is all of the stuff that we've
done with PowerPoint and many of you may
have already used the PowerPoint
designer which helps you translate your
content
to something that's more appealing and
better understandable by your audience
some ridiculous number I can't remember
the exact number but it's a it's you
know over a quarter of all slides are
are now being produced or augmented by a
PowerPoint designer and I like this
example of something that's come out of
Microsoft research that actually uses
natural language understanding to help
people get their messages across better
so the text on this slide was clean
energy can help our country save twenty
four billion dollars a year sounds like
a lot but it doesn't really mean
anything to me
understanding that text we can then
translate it into something that's
relevant for people and let them know
that that's about seven dollars per
person in the u.s. that becomes an
interesting way to understand that and
so the other examples though both both
of these are examples of how we're using
our tools to improve people's
experiences and get help them get what
they want to get done now and in the
future as the tools get better but I
also want to highlight some of what we
were talking about how about the fact
that our tools impact people's attention
impact what we choose to do and how we
choose to do them and there are actually
examples there in the video you saw
focus assist help avoid distractions
this is another example that I really
like particularly because it draws on my
research so I just sort of selfishly
find it find it fun draws out my
research and also research that I've
done with Sean st. Paul and other folks
at Microsoft Research and we spent years
studying micro productivity and how do
you understand the small ways that
people can get things done how you know
we get we have fragmented time how can
you help people be focused and how can
you help people when their time is
fragmented get things done in those
spare moments and so this is something
that we've then recently worked on with
the office folks to think about how you
help people stay in the flow and kind of
offload the small tasks that don't need
to get done while you're doing it so
that they can be done later
so here persons
they wanted to adding a picture of an
HVAC scintillation going into your email
and searching for that particular
picture is time-consuming and a lot of
work and distracting you but every we
all leave these notes everybody does
this now we can automatically identify
them pull them out for you to do later
and even when it's something that we see
and can understand we can provide
intelligent assistance as well so here
we can actually start surfacing places
where we think that picture might be and
right after this session there's a
session on micro productivity that I
encourage you to attend didn't learn
more about that and then finally you
know the impact that we have on people
can be short-term but just in the same
way that our tools grow over time the
impact can also be one that improves
people's experiences with computers over
time as well and this is the presenter
coach example that I mentioned earlier
and I think we're gonna see more and
more examples of our tools helping
people learn and grow and get better
because you know artificial intelligence
is cool because it can scale human
intelligence but what that means is that
the cultivating human intelligence and
what people can do is becoming even more
important and more impactful and then so
these are sort of the four areas that I
like to highlight in that video and
they're the result of this shift that we
were talking about to the web and we're
still in the middle of this shift we
don't really know where it's going we
need research and deep thought to help
us understand and to move into the
future of productivity in a way that's
intentional and good for the world
around us and for that reason we're
announcing today a one
million dollar Microsoft productivity
research request for proposals and we're
calling for research in these four basic
areas so we're interested in
understanding interaction and sensing
what does it mean to interact with the
world how does technology augment our
existing things that we want to get done
how do we use natural language for this
how do we use new devices and new
interaction more debt modalities and we
actually as part of this RFP have a
bunch of hardware available as well so
there are surface hub twos and hololens
twos and connects for as sure that you
can use to really deeply understand new
form factors and new ways of working
we're also interested and calling for
research related to machine learning and
machine teaching you know and this is
like there's tons of research and tons
of things pushing the boundaries of
machine learning to machine teaching
we're particularly interested in things
that relate to some of the unique
challenges we have at this company you
know how do you learn over large scale
customer data in a way that's
privacy-preserving how we can't how do
you learn how do you help our customers
build their own models of learning so we
don't even have to interact with their
data they can go apply the machine
learning how do we help people with
structure in the data you know machine
learning is very very kind of leaf node
centric there's lots of labels how do we
extract structure from that data and how
do we allow people to communicate
structure to the learning algorithms so
that they can use people's real
knowledge and not just a like this is
relevant or this is not feedback symbol
we're also interested in research
related to attention and engagement
understanding how our tools influence
people and how we can have them
influence us in a way that meets our
goal
versus doesn't because the truth is
everything we build influences people
whether we like it or not we need to be
intentional and thoughtful about that
and then finally we're also looking for
research related to collaboration and
human learning how do we coach people
how do we help people grow over time you
know and here actually particularly
interesting to think think about the way
organizations are changing as well you
know Microsoft is really created to
serve enterprises so the core of
Microsoft is an enterprise company what
does it mean as the nature of
enterprises are changing as freelance
work becomes more and more common how is
that going to impact the kinds of tools
that we need to be building so we're
going to we're offering up a million
dollars plus Hardware in grants up to
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars
the deadline is in two months on October
16th and I hope to see proposals from
all of you this is just one of the ways
that you can engage with the Microsoft
community and you know sandy listed a
bunch of ways this faculty summit is
clearly one send us your students as
interns and I know a bunch of you also
work deeply already with folks at
Microsoft
[Applause]